-This is such a very excitin
time to be Jenny Slate.
You have a Netflix special
You have a new book.
And congratulations.
You just got engaged.
-I did!
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Was it fun?
Was it a good engagement story
-It was a very good
engagement story.
He proposed to me in France.
-Oh, that's wonderful.
-Isn't that so romantic?
And then -- And it was --
It was very lovely.
And then the
post-engagement period
where you're like,
"Oh, my goodness.
It's happening."
It's still happening. Yeah
-Yeah, good.
-Yeah.
It happened to me. That's nice
And it continued from France
into the United States.
-That's great.
-Yeah.
-It got through customs.
-It got through customs,
the joy.
-This is really, though --
This has must have been
so exciting for your hometown --
very proud of you.
-Oh, yeah.
-And -- A local business took --
-A business.
-Made the effort...
-Mm-hmm.
-...to use their signage..
-Yes.
-...to congratulate you and Ben.
-Yeah.
-Were you happy
when you saw this?
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
I --
I -- Happy --
-"Milton's own Jenny Slate
is engaged.
Congrats, Jenny and Ben."
-I know.
First of all, I --
thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
I grew up in this town
in, like, a haunted house
in the middle of the woods
Stayed inside the house.
Don't know anyone from the town.
Okay?
That's nice. Secondly, Dairy
Freeze is like the holy plac
smack-dab between my parents
and my grandparents' house
And we were never
allowed to go there.
And I would beg, like, every
time, like, "Please, please!
Like, riding in the car,
like, slamming on the window
And my mom would be like,
"You're lactose intolerant
We can't!"
[ Laughter ]
And so, yeah.
The fact that, first of all,
this place knows that I exis
is a miracle in itself.
-Yeah.
-Then the fact
that I have overcome
my lactose intolerance --
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
An achievement.
-Yeah.
-And then, of course,
the engagement
to the man of my dreams,
you know --
-Yeah. This really
ticks a lot of boxes.
-Lay me down. I'm dead.
-This whole thing, yeah.
-Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, that's usually where
it's like, two-for-one hot dogs.
"Do you like wieners?"
or whatever.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And they were like,
"You know, no.
They're going
to have to just risk
that there's two-for-one
hot dogs tonight.
We have to promote Jenny."
-That's right. They have
to promote my engagement.
I'll also say that this happened
on a day when I was in the town.
And I'm really glad
I didn't see it,
'cause I would have completely
like, floored the car
into the Dairy Freeze.
-Oh, driven --
Yeah, like I would have been
like, "Oh, my God!!"
[ Laughter ]
-I want to talk about your book,
which is so lovely.
-Thank you.
-And I imagine
you agree to write a book first.
And then you
have to write the book.
And that must be
so overwhelming,
that burden of pressure.
-You know what? It is.
And it is also a joy to writ
a book, and I love this book
But I am a terrible
procrastinator.
-Yes. I think a lot of peopl
in our field are.
-Whoa, yeah. And also, at
the time, loved to smoke weed.
-Oh, right, right, right.
-Yeah.
So it was kind of like,
"Yeah, I'll definitely do this
I'll just, like,
take a quick break for one sec."
-Yeah.
-Then like eight months pass
and I wake up. I'm like --
[ Gasps ]
[ Laughter ]
But, yeah, but it was lovely
to write it
and also to decide,
"Hey, guess what?
Got to stop smoking weed."
-Yeah.
-You also --
It very much strikes me
as the book you wanted to write.
-Yes.
-Which it must be so lovel
to have that moment of jus
taking control and being,
"Oh, you know what?
I have things to express
that other people would
never express this way."
And it seemed like
you really enjoyed yourself.
-I'm really glad
that you say that.
I did enjoy myself.
I think the book is funny,
but it's -- It's very sweet,
which is kind of like an
interesting position
to take in today's world.
-Yeah. No, I think we all
could use a little sweetness
I did want to talk
about the cover,
because you kind of look at it
and it looks sweet.
And then you zoom in,
and you're like, "Oh,
I don't think I've ever seen
like, a hamburger
on a cornucopia before."
-Yes, yeah.
-There's like a beer --
Is that a beer can?
-That's a beer can.
I asked for the bronto.
-Yeah, the brontosaurus.
-And I'm pretty sure --
-Yeah, there you go.
-I asked for the hot dog.
-Oh, there's the hot dog.
-There's a hot dog. Yeah.
And then they just put a bra
and a beer there because..
-Yeah.
-...that makes sense, as well.
-And when you saw that,
were you just --
I'm always blown away when
artists, like, physical artists,
when you ask them to do
something, and it comes back -
I'm always just blown away
by their skill
and what they can do.
Were you so happy when you saw
the cover of this book?
-I was. I was so, so happy
because, like, there's a version
of this in my nightmare
where it's just like a bagel
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Just, like --
Wait, what?
Just, like, a big Star of David,
and they're like,
"No, this is your book."
They're like,
"Your book has arrived."
It's just the Old Testament.